the Joe Rogan experience and the regular
world just for whatever reason they've
just tasted it or they've they've
adjusted to it but they're they have a
very very difficult time some of them do
was the closest you've ever felt to that
like have you ever gotten close to the
feeling of like what have you done in
life that has given you the adrenaline
high what's your highest adrenaline rush
I guess I'm asking the probably the most
nervous I ever got was when I was
fighting when I was doing martial arts
and because there was a nervous for a
good reason it's like you might get
[ __ ] up it's really possible you might
get kicked in the head but the second
most nervous was before I did stand up
for the first time I was [ __ ] my
pants man I was really [ __ ] nervous
why hi John no I don't you livingroom
funny like were you high school funny I
was locker room funny I was uh I would
make my friends laugh in the locker room
does that's I got talked to him by a
good buddy of mine my friend Steve
Graham I'm still good friends with he
talked me into it him and my friend ed
shorter they just they talked him into
it I would make them laugh right you
know and but I thought that they were
laughing cuz doing my friends and I
thought like everybody else gonna think
I'm an [ __ ] oh you thought like
they're just being polite
well it's all that too and like my sense
of humor was [ __ ] up because it was
all fighters you know and so everybody
was like they were hard men so you had
to have like a certain sting to your
gallows humor well everybody was on
their way to go kick people in the head
it was just a weird life you know it was
very very strange way to be 15 right you
know have 15 16 17 that was like my
whole life that wasn't the adrenaline
rush the adrenaline rush of doing
stand-up was unexpected that's why I
freaked me out because I didn't think I
was gonna be so nervous no [ __ ] my
pants I just didn't have a background in
performing and right before I was going
up there I was thinking all the times
when I I fought and I should be
comfortable doing this right but I was
[ __ ] [ __ ] my pants
I was so terrible oh so I was so
horrified it was in Boston a place
called stitches are they still there
August 27 1988 no no you know the day
yeah you made me cry that's awesome why
do you remember that
I don't know I always remembered it say
it again august 27 1988 because
naturally everything i hear i have to
put through a filter of how does this
affect me so I'm sitting there going
what was I doing
August 27 1988 I just graduated high
school in June and where was i working i
was we're gonna buy right liquors and
[ __ ] like that and it would be two years
before i would go on to the stage at
Rascals in Eatontown between the mom all
on the CB square mile and try it myself
and i didn't just not don't west orange
no that's that's up north ours is down
in like by Asbury Park this place was
like south yeah I did that one too as
well yeah as a pro I went in an open mic
night just because and I didn't tell my
[ __ ] friends because I was terrified
my friends would be like why do you
think you're funny in stem I was not the
funniest of my friends so I wasn't
sitting there going like yeah man come
support me I kind of did it on the sly
and stuff and and I did five minutes and
I made like one joke that really worked
a bit about sucking my own dick and that
wound up in clerks like it was tested in
front of the audience so I was like well
I know that might get a laugh and stuff
so what was how long was your first beat
and was it open mic he's open mic yeah I
think they gave you five minutes and I
don't think I even had five minutes I
think I had four what did you do observe
no I just I just told some terrible
jokes terrible just literally setup
punchline yeah yeah yeah yeah they were
awful the stuff that I'd written
you know just where did you write them
down yeah yeah yeah
I even had a piece of paper that I
brought with me on stage because those
terrified I was gonna forget a lot of
guys bro you knew you were a pro when
you can put that paper away I'm about to
cry that's so [ __ ] sweet man a young
you how old are you at this point I was
21 so why'd you wait so long after it
has to be 21 to get up booze to go in a
nightclub you know that's what I thought
apparently I was wrong though and you
they would allow you as a performer to
go in there younger but I didn't know
this at the time I thought you had to be
21 so I waited until I was 21 which was
August 11th and then I went up artist 27
what was the what got the biggest laugh
who knows you know the [ __ ] day and
you can't remember the material was
terrible I try to think past as quickly
as possible the and one choke that I
remember all right this is my impression
of a good-looking girl getting pulled
over by a cop like to realize how fast
we're going
no do you like my tits yes I do here's a
warning like it was that bad that's how
bad that's how bad the comedy I was
slinging I wanted to take you home man
and put you on a show like that's an
adorable joke ladies and gentlemen wait
a second how many years before news
radio is that um 88 was six years so
technically if one follows the journey
backwards that [ __ ] terrible joke
lands you eventually on Newsradio
yeah in a way and get you this fund of
welding yeah in a way
let's not mock that joke anymore that's
a good strong well that's what the weird
wings of a butterfly that becomes a
hurricane right like we need to go back
in your life and think about weird
little left's you took or rights you
took
[Applause]